America's Got Talent star Zuri Craig has
died he was 44 years old
[Music]
the singer's family confirmed the tragic
news on Instagram writing quote it is
with profound sadness that we announced
the transition of our beloved Son
brother and friend Zuri Craig please
honor our privacy during this
unimaginable time of mourning no cause
of death was revealed but the family's
message says more details will be shared
are you nervous extremely extremely
nervous alongside singing partner
Jeffrey Lewis Zuri competed in season 10
of AGT in 2015.
you're the great move man we are best
friends and we're singers
[Music]
[Music]
guest judge Michael Buble tapped his
Golden Buzzer for the group
I ain't got no planes
[Music]
they got the golden buzzers
[Applause]
throughout that run the duo was a
favorite among the panel and audience
they ultimately placed fifth by season's
end I gotta tell you it looked great it
sounded great this is Tuesday Night Live
I felt like I was sitting in a church on
Sunday morning when I signed on to this
show to find Superstars fellas you've
arrived
foreign